[Musique]
après 15 jours de travaux de
sécurisation des falaises de Salazie
l'air des 48 a été réouverte ce mercredi
8 février grâce à l'efficacité du
travail des agents du Département et des
cordistes de l'entreprise GTOI le
président du Département Cyril Melchior
est le maire de Salazie Stéphane fois 5
se sont rendus sur place à cette
occasion Cyril Melchior a annoncé la
mise en place d'une brigade affectée
uniquement la route de Salazie
nous avons décidé de faire en sorte que
la Salazie il y ait une brigade d'agents
du service des routes de département qui
soit mobilisés et affectés au territoire
de Salazie nous avons la route
départementale qui va vers grand illette
et celle qui se dirige vers helbour donc
c'est un île Linéa de route important en
zone de montagne jusqu'à maintenant les
agents étaient positionnés à bras pas
non et bien nous allons installer une
brigade dédiée au territoire de Salazie
se sont à peu près une dizaine d'agents
avec un chef d'équipe qui pourront
intervenir le cas échéant assez
rapidement pour le maire de la commune
il s'agit désormais de trouver des
solutions à mettre en place pour
sécuriser sur le long terme la desserte
du cirque
il faut qu'on continue à réfléchir tous
ensemble et le président du conseil
départemental a annoncé aujourd'hui de
voir comment quelle est la possibilité
d'avoir un nouveau tracé dans cette
route on est en capacité de faire des
routes sur la mer on est en capacité de
faire des routes et de faire le
basculement d'eau d'est en ouest on est
donc capable de faire des routes
sécurisées plusieurs solutions sont
envisagées par le service des routes du
département dans les solutions
envisageables il y a différentes
techniques il y a à la fois de la
sécurisation passive sur des techniques
très localisées comment faire
régulièrement c'est-à-dire avoir du
grillage paquet des écrans dynamiques
des gabions des écrans mixtes tout un
panel de solutions
adapté par rapport à la situation très
précise la sécuriser il y a des
solutions qui sont un petit peu plus
lourdes comme des demi tunnels qui ont
été à un moment évoqués par le BRGM dans
la section entre leurs aides et
catholicaire ce sont trois kilomètres de
linéaires on a une falaise qui arrive
qui est juste au dessus de la route donc
c'est donc une des solutions techniques
qui pourra être envisageable et enfin
dans les solutions plus lourdes il y a
effectivement la possibilité
éventuellement de changer l'itinéraire
donc de placer la route sur un endroit
moins exposé mais avec tout un tas de
difficultés
un travail sans relâche pour sécuriser
les déplacements des saladiens mais
aussi pour répondre aux enjeux
sanitaires sociaux éducatifs et
économiques
[Musique]